welcome ladies and gentlemen welcome to
AEI I'm Arthur Brooks president of AEI
and I'm just delighted to welcome my
friend Sheryl Sandberg the chief
operating officer of Facebook they join
us in this conversation here today it's
been a busy day here today some of you
have seen that we've had many events but
this is something I've been looking
forward to for a long time this is a an
interview that we've been hoping to do
for for months and months and months
we've had this on the books now for I
guess four months and and this is as
many of you know one of the last events
we'll be doing here in this building but
I think it's kind of a capstone because
we're gonna talk about so many of the
issues that are important to you than
important to me I'm gonna give you a
quick bio it's not really that necessary
but it's so impressive the person that I
have with me on the stage that I want to
talk I want to dwell a little bit on
what success really looks like in
America today Sheryl has been the chief
operating officer at Facebook since 2008
when she came to Facebook Facebook has
70 million users which seemed like a lot
at the time and 550 employees the like
button had yet to be invented Facebook
today has a 1.6 billion users over a
billion users every day 70 million
wasn't that many turns out and more than
13,000 employees she's done a lot more
than than just that
and I say that just that under
advisement she's the author of the 2013
bestseller lean in women work in the
will - and she's the founder of lean in'
org which is a nonpartisan nonprofit
organization dedicated to empowering
women to achieve their ambitions I
should note that lean in has spawned
lean in circles of women who are talking
about the issues that they're faced that
they're facing and and now I think that
they're how many how many 28,000 28,000
rain in circles this is social capital
building this is activism it really it's
best believe it or not Sheryl began her
career here in DC good things in
entrepreneurship can happen in DC that's
it's kind of a rarity for Silicon Valley
executives after after studying
economics at Harvard she went to work at
the World Bank and later serve the chief
of staff in the US Treasury Department
during the Clinton administration
Cheryl welcome to ya thank you thank you
all for being here and thank you for
your friendship and for inviting me here
today I'm delighted delighted to have
you here you know we've been looking
forward to having this conversation for
a long time I should note that you and I
met in 2006 I was still teaching at
Syracuse and you were still at Google
and we were both really interested in
philanthropy and I had written this
controversial book about who gives more
to charity conservatives or liberals
conservatives and and and I was talking
about it Stanford and Sheryl was really
interested in the topic and came to a
little talk that I gave him we had
supper after witness admit that is the
one of the most interesting people I've
ever met and so it's great that we're
gonna meet again on the stage for this
particular conversation sure all I've
got a lot I've got a lot of questions
and so does our audience I want to get
right to it a near Washington DC kind of
in the belly of the political beast
although AEI is about ideas and not
politics but that notwithstanding you
and I saw each other a month ago because
Facebook was in the middle of it wasn't
really a controversy but it was
something that had flared up in which
people had asserted that that the
trending topics at Facebook had been
gettin ippol ated or had had done
something to suppress conservative views
and I don't want to get into the weeds
but quant you to discuss the controversy
and how it was dealt with and and then
we can move on to other topics well
thank you for that so Facebook's a
platform for all ideas and all voices
and as Arthur said we have 1.6 billion
people using the platform which means
all ideas have to be able to be
expressed trending topics is a small
product which says which topics are
trending we have a small editorial team
most of the work done at Facebook
doesn't involve editorial but that was
important because we needed some human
editors so for example without that
every day at noon lunch would be
trending so we need some some human
touch to get this right and dinner
around 5:00 or 6:00 we every day that's
where everyday lunch try
this line spinner and so we had a next
contractor on that team who accused us
of having a liberal bias and that's a
pretty important accusation and it's one
we take seriously it's also one which
frankly rang true to some people because
there is concern that Silicon Valley
companies have a liberal bias and so we
took it very seriously we did a thorough
investigation and we didn't find a
liberal bias but we still took
additional steps to be more rigorous in
our approach to running the editorial
team put out for our team stronger
guidelines there was a list we were
using to validate sites we got rid of
that there was no list we were relying
on we also had this meaning that you
nicely flew across the country to attend
we had a full range of conservative
voices and as you remember we didn't
just talk about this topic we talked
about how they were using Facebook to
get their voice out and this really
matters to us
it is a political time and we're proud
of the role we play in elections not
just here but around the world the
vision of Facebook was to enable
individuals to connect but to connect
not just to their friends and family but
also to the people who are representing
them and who they want to represent them
so in this presidential election
Facebook has been very broadly used it's
worth noting that Donald Trump has more
fans than both Bernie Sanders and
Hillary Clinton combined we're also
proud of our use by people who are
already elected so every member of
Congress has a Facebook presence and
some of them one of my favorite examples
is Elise Stefanik who happens to be the
youngest member of Congress post very
frequently and really explain themselves
she posts almost after every vote she
takes to explain why she did it and that
is the vision of what we're doing and
one we're excited to see keep coming to
fruition all around the world so your
investigation of this turned up what and
and and what engineering solutions just
as a as a basic matter did you did you
implement it turned up no systemic bias
right but we still take it really
seriously and so we have it's
interesting we think a lot about
diversity mm-hmm at Facebook and you
know it's something my industry or
industry struggled which we've struggled
with and we have a managing bias class
that all of our leaders and a lot of our
employees have taken
then I was part of helping to create and
we focused on racial bias age bias
gender bias national bias and we're
gonna add in a scenario now on political
bias so that as part of we think about
helping people understand different
points of view and being open to
different points of view we're dealing
with political bias as well going
forward
that's really interesting and I think
that's really encouraging - I spent a
lot of time in in Northern California
because I fundraise all the time and and
when I'm when I'm in Northern California
one of the things that you find is that
it's just it's kind of hard to find
people that have a conservative or
religious worldview in that part of the
world you find that it's a you need to
work harder to find employees and
executives that can understand that you
are you looking for more people that
have that worldview perhaps at Facebook
and and other companies as well
we think to build a product at 1.6
billion people use you need diversity
and what you really want is cognitive
diversity which is what you're talking
about different thoughts intellectual
diversity ideas actual diversity now how
do you get that you can get that by
having diversity of the population so
that's everything from age gender to
nationality to personality types - as
you're saying ideological and idea
diversity you also have to create an
environment which rewards that we've
always tried to run the company where
when people speak the truth to power
we're very open that gets rewarded you
know we have this a famous story of a
young intern telling mark this is years
ago you're not a very good public
speaker you should get better at that
this is summer intern and it's you know
I think about six years ago mark said to
him you're right
and thanked him publicly you're right
I'm not good at that yet and I better
get better if you look at mark now he's
fantastic public speaker yeah what
happened to the intern it's an important
question
the interns got hired at Facebook
Facebook oh at Facebook I was at a
meeting at Facebook and I was saying one
thing I really wanted to do and then a
young engineer I had never met in a
group of 200 people raised his hand and
said one of the worst ideas he's ever
heard was exactly what I just said I
wanted to do and what I did with that is
I thanked him then and I
to the entire company and thanked him
publicly for disagreeing with me and
explained that he was right and he was
and so you need people with different
opinions and you need an environment
where people can express those opinions
and we work on both that's interesting
to you as an executive do you surround
yourself with people that disagree with
you on purpose do you hire people to
surround you to disagree with you I mean
I've actually heard that as a I mean
Lincoln did that a lot of successful
leaders throughout history have done it
but it takes some intestinal fortitude
and it takes a willingness to tell
people that they're allowed to disagree
with it so you know if I make a mistake
today
I'm gonna say too much not too little
right but if I never make that if I
never speak about that openly what are
the chances that someone who works for
me is like Cheryl you really talk too
much in that meeting right zero but if I
say I want to make sure I don't take too
much air time in a meeting I can walk
out of a meeting and someone can say to
me you asked me to tell you you
should've let me talk more in that
meeting interested but you have to raise
it yourself because people are not gonna
speak truth to power unless you make
that apparent and that's how we get not
just different voices into the company
but make sure we're listening to
different voices let's talk a little bit
about just did that what would not would
spawn that particular controversy we
started it with but the the broader
issue of the dissemination of news and
information it's interesting when you're
a fast-growing company like Facebook you
never know what business you're gonna be
in next I mean you're you've looked been
incredibly successful at having
situational awareness and exploiting
opportunities I mean this has been one
of the key case studies when I was
teaching in the business school I would
I would talk about Facebook and say it's
just extraordinary how they see
opportunities through the windshield and
grab them as opposed to having a 10-year
strategic plan as if you are an old
industry now that means that there are
things like news dissemination that you
didn't know you were gonna be in ten
years and you are now and the difficulty
that poses it seems to me is that you
don't that your employees don't have
journalism training now if you were at
the New York Times you wouldn't have
people who only have technical training
who are trying to write the news and
spread the news they have to go to J
school that's not necessarily the best
way to do it but I that it begs the
question what do you do to maintain it
as really
standards when you've suddenly gotten
into an industry like that word that you
weren't
I guess prepared for or your employees
weren't prepared for how do you think of
that
what clear about the industry we're in
in a company we're in we're a tech
company we're not a media company right
so we're not trying to hire journalists
and we're not trying to write news when
you think about news feed which is the
product most people spend most of their
time with on Facebook the way we think
about it is if you were sitting down
with your friends or family at dinner
tonight what are the ten things you'd
want to see and we determine that mostly
with machines and algorithms and the way
we determine that is important the
average the median person on Facebook we
have 1,500 stories you could read that
day now I welcome all of you to spend
that much time on Facebook because that
would be fantastic for us but you're
probably not going to certainly not the
AAI employees because I know they're
super busy
we're surfacing the stuff you most want
to see first and how do we do that we
basically look at the things you do so
when I choose to connect to AEI or I
choose to follow your post if I interact
with your post more if when I see your
posts I like and follow them I will
therefore I will therefore see more of
it the top thing in my newsfeed last
night was my friend Marnie and Phil it
was their wedding anniversary now why
did I see that top of my newsfeed
because they're two of my closest
friends and I'm constantly liking and
commenting on their on their on their
their posts so I saw that more
frequently we also really invite people
to give us feedback there's an arrow on
every post and you can say hide this
post you can also go to anyone's
Facebook page or profile and say I want
to see this first and so news feed gets
better the more information you give us
about what you want to see so you would
just as soon in the the news function
have less human interaction with it and
have it be more automated such that it
is there's less editorial discretion
you're always working for Less editorial
in human discussions and these things
right yes and there's very little
there's very there's very little
Facebook there is some as there was with
what's trending topics again to make
sure things like lunch don't trend every
day at noon but but for the most part
this is machine based algorithmically
based based on the actions you take yeah
and and are you worried that there are
certain sort of pathological viewpoints
that are and you know hate speech and
discrimination and things that were sort
of against that are gonna keep coming up
and then maybe there should be more
intrusion on a bit or Tory level or is
that there's that something that we have
to deal with is a cost of doing business
well we have content policies and
there's content policies we take very
seriously so are things which have no
place on Facebook there's no place on
hate on Facebook for hate for violence
for terrorism and any of that content is
pulled down and pulled off the site as
soon as we can find it then that does
require some editorial discretion with
it with the help of some technology yes
and it really heavily relies on people
reporting that content to us with 1.6
billion users we're not gonna catch
everything but we also have one point
six users who can report things and they
do report things and when we see
something that is hate that is violence
that is terrorism we act quickly to take
it down and not just the content but we
work hard to take down the accounts
oh no kidding yeah now that actually
leads to some of the problems that we're
having in the United States this topic
does we and I think that I think most
people here probably agree that there's
too much political polarization or at
least an unpleasant level of political
polarization is something that I've
written about a lot and I knew that you
care about and and one of the concerns
is that we're able to tailor the
information that we get through social
media so much that we get something that
social scientists who always have a
fancy word for everything so they can
get tenure it's they call it epistemic
closure and what that means is I'm
closed to outside views and I can I can
tailor everything that comes in you know
one of the things that people are often
concerned about is the social media
makes that easier and easier and easier
you can really cocoon yourself
completely from it and you know this
leads to an experience that's not very
enriching I think so I know you're
concerned about this what is your view
on this do you believe that Facebook is
inadvertently leading to epistemic
closure
boy what a social site no it's a great
question it's an important question and
I do think it's a common fear that some
people have I also think it's not true
so media companies have certainly come
to not all but most a more specific
point of view over the last number of
decades when you choose to go to fox or
CNN or HuffPo or new york times you're
making a decision about what point of
view for the most part you want to see
and you know that on the way in when you
come to Facebook
what Facebook really does and here's
another sociology term we strengthen
your your weak ties not your strong ties
so psychologists think about your strong
ties and your weak ties your strong ties
are the five to seven people you are in
constant touch with your mom your
husband your wife your partner your
child your best friend Facebook doesn't
change your interactions with those
people because you know what those
people are doing and you're in touch
with them anyway what Facebook does do
is enable you efficiently to communicate
with a lot more people your weak ties
the people you've worked with at your
last company you don't see every day
the people you went to high school with
three of my high school friends are in
this audience today it's really nice the
people who you're not in touch with on a
daily basis so Facebook strengthens your
weak ties and for the most part when you
go from a smaller group to a broader
group you go to broader political points
of view so we believe strongly that
Facebook actually widens the points of
view you see particularly when you
compare it to getting news from one news
outlet which a lot of people do they
certainly do and so is there any way to
inject more or weak ties with
alternative points of view into people's
Facebook feeds is there any way to do
that well from the American Enterprise
Institute into their well I'm glad you
asked the question exactly this way
because it is part of the discussion
we're having which is Facebook's not
going to inject anything to anyone right
that's not what we're gonna do we don't
have a point of view we're not trying to
make you have a point of view we're
enabling you to connect with more people
so certainly anyone is watching her here
we invite you to connect to a EEI to
connect to Arthur Brooks if you want to
so you can hear those points of view our
average person has a hundred and fifty
friends or pages they follow and over
time those numbers tend to go up and so
we do see that people are broadening out
the voices they hear from over time and
we provide the technology that makes it
possible to do that let's move on a
little bit to the impact of tech on
society and on the economy because this
is something you've written and talked
an awful lot about and the you and I
have discussed and I know it's really
important to you you know you have a
long-standing relationship with Larry
Summers and and with a lot of our mutual
friends who've written a good deal about
inequality economic inequality
inequality of opportunity and I know you
feel strongly about it it's a big issue
in politics today clearly some of the
populist
friends that we've seen in the current
presidential election has a great deal
to do with inequality if not of income
certainly inequality of opportunity
some people even some of the scholars
here at AEI have written about the
extent to which the structure of the
economy is is creating enclaves of
winners and losers
the people who being there they're being
facilitated into their the success that
they earned by the new economy and
others who are being kind of excluded by
that now you're in a part of the economy
in Northern California where you see big
big winners a lot and it's sort of hard
to see some of the people who have been
left behind so the people from Port
Clinton Ohio where the plant shut down
etc what's your view on how the new tech
economy that you're part of how it's
changing inequality for the winners and
losers in the new economy the
post-industrial revolution as it were
and what are the trends that you see and
what can we do together to ameliorate
some of these trends inequalities
arising and inequality is important and
so it's something we all need to be
concerned about and as an industry tech
we have to ask ourselves what world do
we play and all new technology but
particularly technology that grows
quickly raises real challenges and also
has real opportunities and the
challenges are real every time there's
been real technological change from the
Industrial Revolution on as you say it
changes job models that changes economic
earth it changes patterns of what the
labor markets need and and there there's
adaptation that has that has to happen
there's also real opportunities created
so you look at job creation the Apple
AppStore is eight years old and create
600,000 jobs and I think sometimes
people think that tech only creates tech
jobs and that's not true
Facebook at Facebook and market around
the world and most of those are not tech
businesses this is the local plumber the
local Baker who are using Facebook to
start a business and most job growth in
this country and all others comes from
small a small entrepreneurship my
favorite example is a woman I met named
Emily she started a company called sword
and plough while she was serving in the
US military with her sister she was
deployed in Afghanistan they used
Facebook to communicate they then used
[ __ ] to sell their products and they
take military materials so tents
uniforms and they make them into bags
and accessories and fashionable goods
they can sell fast forward a few years
she's now a veteran her business is
thriving and they employ 40 veterans
doing this work and servicing their
customers and so technology unleashes
entrepreneurship that's a pretty
low-tech business they're selling
handbags and they're selling selling
accessories I do think as a NASA as a
society as policymakers in this town we
have a real role to play to make sure
we're well positioned to take advantage
of the opportunities and meet the
challenges and it really comes down to
education there's six hundred thousand
open computing jobs in our economy our
universities will turn out 43,000
computer science grads this year not all
of them were born and raised in the
United States and even have the ability
to work here so we have a demand for
jobs we have an economy that needs jobs
and we're not investing in the right
education to get people there
this means math this means science this
means computer science it's particularly
a challenge for women and minorities who
are getting even less of the education
they need but it's a really big
opportunity for us and one we're not
we're not meeting now I think we need to
start thinking of computer science as a
language
we teach reading we teach writing we
teach computer science in our schools
and we are a long way from there but we
have to change we have to change fast
the education reform is something we do
a ton of at AEI and and one of the
reasons is because we believe that the
human potential is a right that people
should have and should understand that
they have one of the things that we're
talking about along these lines is
trying to reform education such that
people have real skills even coming out
of high school and beyond just the fact
that not enough people know how to code
or go on to become computer scientists
in college an interesting fact from our
point of view is that there are 300,000
skilled welding jobs open in this
country this year while we have over a
thirty percent unemployment rate for
example for young african-american men
these are skills needs mismatch and so
it's certainly not just encoding in high
tech things it's in the skilled trades
that are dignified pay well and hard to
outsource what's your view just in
general on what we need to do urge
in K through 12 education that could
help to solve some of these problems to
get some of the skills entrepreneurship
computers encoding vocational and
technical education maybe some
apprenticeships what should we do now
and how do we go about that we have
schools that have you know churned out
11 percent of graduates who can read for
decades and that needs to change our
schools need to educate people so that
they can read so that they can write so
that they can take advantage of
vocational vocational education we need
to not be afraid to train people for the
jobs we have and we need to not be
afraid to take a harder look at the
basics because it really is the basics
of reading of math of science that
prepare us to do any of this to learn
other trades and if we can't give kids
the fundamentals by young ages we fail
later on in the system and so I'm glad
for all the work you do and there's
probably nothing more important for all
of us
then STEM education and educational
reform in this country hmm let's go we
talked about how we can enrich people
who would have more skills from the tech
industry but let's look how the tech
industry can lift people up at the
bottom who don't happen to be in this
industry
on this stage I interviewed Bill Gates
some months ago and he's very very
concerned with the extent to which the
post-industrial revolution has had a
hard time reaching down to the bottom of
the economy and alleviating really
alleviating poverty I mean it's it's
easy to see and this is related to what
we talked about a minute ago how the
post-industrial revolution is is really
great for some but how can we add more
human capital to people at the very
bottom of the ladder both here the
United States and especially around the
world where poverty is is a grinding
phenomenon and ruining generations of
people it's such an important question
and one of the things we focus on in
facebook is connectivity so there are
four billion people in the world who are
not connected to data have no access to
data and that means that they are cut
off from health care information job
information that their voice can't be
heard it's a particular issue for women
not surprisingly in the developing world
women are 25% less likely to be
connected so the question is how do you
solve that how do you solve the problem
you solve the problem by actually
addressing its root causes and for most
people its economic
not technical on the economics you know
the world bank puts global absolute
poverty at a dollar ninety a day ten
percent of the world's population lives
under that line the average connected
Facebook user in the u.s. their implicit
cost of data don't worry this isn't
gonna pop up on your cell bill this week
is a dollar a day that means that people
in this room are spending in facebook
data half of what the poorest people in
the world are living on so we know that
in order to get them connected so we can
hear from their voices we need to lower
the cost of data Facebook has a program
called free basics it's an open platform
where we provide free services free data
to people and it includes health
information includes job information
basic information they need and so far
with that and internet org we've
connected 25 million people we face some
real challenges in these programs but
we're gonna keep pushing because those
people deserve the access we get and we
see the benefits for every ten people
who get connected one is lifted out of
poverty already and we can see the
health benefits things like maternal
mortality it's also an issue by the way
mostly economic in the United States
most people who are not connected fall
under thirty thousand dollars a year of
income and so we need to solve that for
one point six of the four billion it is
a technical challenge because they don't
live in areas that have access to three
or four G which is what you need for
data so we've invested in some pretty
creative solutions one of the big ones
is Aquila it is our solar-powered
airplane which can fly for very long
distances at very high altitudes and
beam down connectivity and it has the
wingspan of a 737 but it weighs about as
much as a small car which is why it can
it can accomplish as much with as little
energy we're gonna need things like that
that get creative to get access to the
people who don't have it a couple of
quick follow-up questions on that number
one is just walk us through how somebody
who gets free basic in India for example
how that having that service can be a
facilitator for escaping poverty so just
to tell the story of somebody that where
that happens yeah we've seen us a lot I
mean we've seen examples but people from
mobile phones who are agricultural
workers in the developing world just
using that mobile phone to figure out
what the prices are for the goods
they're selling from their farm and
increase their income visa vie me the
middlemen because they were cut off from
data we have storage through through
free basics of women who have access to
basic maternal health information and
therefore go on to have healthier
pregnancies basic information on
sanitation for their children really
improves health out health outcomes
people who can start businesses not just
for themselves but actually for a whole
village with data from one cell phone
and so if you think about living a life
right now where you have no access to
information and then kind of turning on
the light so to speak access to
information on your own rights in your
own country this is being used in India
for women who are largely in the home to
be informed about their rights and
domestic violence cases pure domestic
violence domestic violence victim you
often have trouble leaving your home so
information I can't get to you in your
home doesn't help you but through free
basics we've had stories of women
accessing information on their rights in
their own country on domestic violence
and being able to connect with services
hmm it's interesting one of the things
that some of our scholars have talked
about is that we tend to say that what
the poor need to not be poor is as a
shelter and food and basic health care
but one of the things that we find that
really lift people out of poverty our
Communications Energy and credit those
are the things that so you can you can
be basically maintained as subsistence
level with those first three things but
if you want to get into something that
looks like the middle class somewhere
you need what we're talking about here
so you mentioned something in passing
that I think is pretty interesting you
said that you face some real challenges
to giving away free data how could you
face challenges in a country I don't
know take India for example what kind of
challenges would you face we face some
real challenges look anytime you try to
disrupt an industry and make something
cheaper you're disrupting an industry
and making something cheaper or giving
it away for free and you know we face
new challenges in India net neutrality
we believe in net neutrality we support
net neutrality it's important to have a
free and open Internet where services
can be delivered not just from companies
like ours but from small startups net
neutrality has also been used
incorrectly in my view in our view to
keep
from to try to keep us and others from
delivering free free services to the
world's poor and I don't think it was
ever intended that way and I think the
debate over time will evolve to the
point where people understand how
important it is for us to provide data
to the world's poor so you get you go
into a market and they're entrenched
competitors are providers of services
that don't like the fact that your
pricing
your service is a zero which is under
theirs and they object to it yeah and it
happens from all from all different
people and people want to protect local
industries but they also you know
sometimes the best of policies can be
can be Mis applied and we've seen that
not just in India but in lots of
countries all over the world
interesting so those these are the legal
challenges that you continue to face and
and okay and and that's I guess what you
would expect let's turn to policy
because we're touching on policy right
now so as you may or may not know you're
in Washington DC and and and I'm just
gonna you know it's it's I'm gonna guess
that the only reason you're here is not
just to sort of see the Washington
Monument and talk to Arthur Brooks you
must be here for something else on this
trip what do you what are you doing so
I'm here with my team Joe Kaplan is here
with me he leads our global public
policy teams and Aaron Egan who runs our
US policy we're here talking to policy
makers because this is a really
important time you don't need me to tell
you where we're at a place where we have
to decide what kind of policy and
regulatory environment we like the
United States in many ways has had the
right policy environment for the tech
industry and other industries to develop
we are a country of entrepreneurs we are
a country that is invested in and
supported innovation and we need to make
sure we have the right policy and
regulatory environment that continues to
do that here and around the world and so
the people who work here both at the
staff level and obviously members of
Congress and people running for office
they really matter in the right
regulatory and policy environment we're
here talking to them interesting so what
kind of regulatory or policy environment
is most conducive to the innovation that
you'd like to see it's gonna help the
American public the most what are the
big changes you'd like to see at the
moment well some of it is changes and
some of it are also maintaining things
and maintaining maintaining that we've
had a free and open internet we've had a
global system where for the most part
you can transfer data between countries
that's really important
one of the big open issues right now is
the transfer of data from the EU to the
US because the legal and regulatory
umbrella under which that has happened
which was safe harbor and now is the
privacy shield is under scrutiny and
under challenge and it's important that
countries and companies enable us to
work across borders a good example is
immigration so Facebook 83% of the
people who use Facebook live outside the
United States more than 80 percent of
our workers live inside the United
States we've been able to do that
because we are able to hire and we've
been able to hire most of the
high-skilled workers we need but the
h-1b situation is basically a crisis for
our company and others because as I said
before 600,000 open jobs 43,000 grads
not all from the US we have to hire
workers and as h-1bs have gotten tighter
and tighter over the last couple years
we've taken jobs that we wanted to hire
in the United States and had to move
them overseas when we move a tech job
overseas we move all the ancillary jobs
around us and so we're trying to conduct
the majority of our business you know
here and we need the immigration system
that lets us do that we had an
interesting report from one of our
scholars that showed that the an average
high skill owner of the United States
generates about five jobs for people who
are born in the United States yeah so
those are the ancillary opportunities
that you're talking about though I
believe that just good public policy
sure and good for everybody along the
way the stock is purchased second about
innovation we might turn back to policy
if we have time but I want to talk a
little bit about innovation at Facebook
is doing some interesting high-profile
things and technologies that are not
what we expect and me again this has
been an opportunistic company that's
found all sorts of innovative
opportunities that that most of us
wouldn't have seen as so when you're
investing in things that are
counterintuitive it really gets a lot of
attention there's got to be some there
there and I'm talking about especially
your investments in virtual reality
through the acquisition of oculus and
and also your work in developing
artificial intelligence can you talk
about that some of the g-wiz stuff that
you've got going out there and just
maybe blow our minds a little bit I
don't know I could blow your minds but I
can certainly talk about investments in
innovation we are making big investments
in technology
we think we'll serve our mission our
mission is to help people share and
connect all over the world artificial
intelligence is really important and I
think sometimes very misunderstood we
are using artificial and machine
learning right now to translate Facebook
into 40 languages that go in 1,800
different directions so the reason
people around the world can communicate
is because of machine learning and basic
AI we're using AI to make Facebook
usable for people who are blind AI can
read the picture in your newsfeed so
that you know what's going on and as we
continue to invest in things machines
can do AI will help us bring us closer
together and that technology is really
important and really important
investment for us virtual reality is not
just fun if people have tried it we have
oculus we have this great headset and
now we have the touch so you can use
your hands that's coming out but it's
actually the greatest empathy the
ultimate empathy device because it
enables you to experience something not
quite realistically but a lot closer one
of my favorite examples is a film called
clouds over syndra which is a
documentary on the real life of a 12
year old syrian girl who's a refugee now
can that make you and I understand what
it's really like to be a refugee of
course not but it can be a lot closer
and it's used from everything to train
surgeons to help people understand the
other human experience when we think
about what technology can do from
beaming down from solar planes at high
altitudes to give tech to give data at
much lower or free cost to the poor to
creating virtual experiences where you
can experience things without the same
kind of travel or life experience to AI
where we can use machines to enhance the
human experience that's pretty exciting
stuff and we're excited to be making
those investments so today no doubt I
will post a picture five years from now
I'm going to be posting an experience to
my Facebook page and that the people who
love me and know me are going to get
that and they're gonna have the
experience that I'm having in a in a way
this isn't less virtual it's more like
being there is this is that's what we're
gonna see this is what these investments
are leading us to is sharing experiences
with people yes it is I mean
I loved your post I think from couple
days ago or last week where you are in
Santa Monica and your kids were more
excited about the beach than your speech
yeah that was surprising
that's not 360 picture the capital
yesterday
yeah 360 picture is cooler you feel more
like you're there and when you think
about trying to experience something
where we all can't travel around the
world I think we can bring experience as
much closer yeah so who knows what it
could look like you know it's it's
something smells weird I'm gonna post
that in a couple of years it's just who
knows what the range of experiences
might be we'd love to make that possible
think we're working on that right now
but we probably you heard it here first
when you think about it you know how
many experiences can you actually have
how many people can you actually touch
how many lives can you actually
understand and when we bring ourselves
closer together as individuals as people
I think the world becomes a little
smaller I think we have hope for the
world to become a little more peaceful
you know on that note I want to take the
last part of our time together to talk
about some of the things you've done
outside of Facebook and sort of your
personal journey you become really a
household name since 2010 not just due
to Facebook but because of lean in and
lean in isn't a book it's kind of a
phenomenon it's an experience a lot of
people are talking about it and they're
experiencing it too to try to enhance
their own lives
you've got the lean in org foundation
the grassroots lean in circles that I
talked about a little bit and just the
phenomenon that the book itself has
created in the ways that affected the
lives it's probably so many people who
are sitting here in the audience and
people who are watching us virtually
part of the message was how important it
is for women who want to find success in
both careers and their families to have
a great partner you emphasized that a
whole lot now as most of us here know
it's been just over a year since you
lost your husband Dave how was the last
year changed what it means for you to
lean in I mean it's an important
question I did a post this Mother's Day
where I talked about how my perspective
obviously changed personally from losing
my husband especially so on so many
effectively you know in Lena and I
really talked about how as a woman your
career can really be benefited and your
life by having a supportive partner and
I still believe that I still believe
that's really important if you can find
it I became a single mother overnight
and I became a single mother with a lot
of resources I don't pretend to have the
experience most single mothers have in
the country but I certainly understand
much more than I did today and what I
understand is that the American family
is evolving and changing since the 1970s
the number of children being raised by
single mothers has more than doubled 30%
of families with children are headed by
a single parent 84 percent of those are
by a single mother now 40 percent of
families of a headed by a single mother
live in poverty compared to 22 percent
headed by a single father and eight
percent headed by two parents and so the
American family is evolving what it is
to be an American family is evolving
certainly the help we provide single
mothers is completely insufficient you
know on a personal note Father's Day was
two days ago
I don't think I ever spent enough time
thinking about what it was like to be a
child in this country and not have a
father on Father's Day but I sure did
two days ago and so I think as we
approach everything from how we interact
with each other to how we think about
the American family we need to
understand that the families of all
things what is your what are your
ambitions for the llenan movement what
do you want to see it do over the next
five years the sequel to the book is in
a movie it's absolutely none of that I
mean we'd like to not have to exist
because we've achieved equality and
everyone's leaning in all the time we
launched the second phase of lean in
together tomorrow which is together
women can and that's really about women
supporting other women and the goal is
very simple equality equality in the
workplace equality in the home half our
countries and half our companies run by
women we're very very far from that we
have 17 countries of hundreds and five
percent of the top jobs and half our
homes and have to work with our children
being done by men
the good news is that this is already at
least about to happen if not starting to
happen I'm super excited about lean in
circles we never thought we'd have
28,000 we grow by almost 100 a week our
goal was a thousand and 28,000 circles
their lean in circles think 10 women
sometimes men who get together once a
month except there's one in Texas with
hundreds of members because they say
everything's bigger in the state of
Texas but they meet once a month and
they come together to support their
ambitions and what we hear from women
all over the world is that this is how
they get raises this is how they get
that voice in their head saying they can
they can not they can't and this is
about cultural change so I'm gonna ask
the men only men only in this audience
raise your hand if someone called you
bossy as a little child mentally or
something you've always a few women told
us others raise your hand if someone
called you bossy as a child girls aren't
bossy and boys aren't called bossy
because we expect them to lead but
leadership is so surprising from a girl
that we call them bossy I say to people
everywhere next time you see a little
girl called bossy often by her own
parents you walk right up and you say
that little girl is not bossy that
little girl has executive leadership
skills I want to pause on something I'm
gonna say it the other way that little
boy has executive leadership skills
there is no audience anywhere in the
world that doesn't have exactly that
reaction
there's no humor when it's a boy and
there's lots of humor when it's a girl
why because humor is about surprising
our expectations so it is actually funny
that a little girl would have executive
leadership skills and that's the problem
to this day in 2016 we expect leadership
for men and not women the campaign we're
launching tomorrow about women helping
other women is really important because
I think there's another myth out there
which is that along with women can't
lead or shouldn't lead it's that women
don't support each other and I think
that is not true women do support each
other and they are supporting each other
and so tomorrow we're asking everyone to
join us at llenan org slash together and
post a picture of a woman who's
at them I've talked to so many women
today who said their problem with
posting tomorrow is they can't decide
which woman to pick because so many
women have supported their career which
is I think against with a lot of people
think and so we come together we work
together towards real equality I'm about
to turn to the audience but I'm going to
ask one more question the reason I say
this because I want those of you who
have questions to get ready to get your
questions ready and and and I'll tell
you the rules as soon as soon as I'm
done with this one this is a tight and
important topic for me this last one and
I've done a lot of research and a lot of
thinking personally about the importance
of work how work dignifies people how
work brings meaning into people's lives
how work is a sanctified ordinary thing
and how important it is for people to be
able to do work whether its formal
worker in for more because it's
voluntary work or work in the home work
has to be done and it's it's something
that people deserve but the people I've
talked to in my research who have the
most satisfying relationship with their
work
are people who can answer the following
question it's not the question you ever
hear in Washington the question here in
Washington is what do you do it's not
the right question why do you do it if
you can answer the why of your work
you're happy what's the why of Sheryl
Sandberg's work to give people voice so
they can reach for their ambitions
across Facebook and lean in Facebook's
about giving voice Facebook is about you
know one of my favorite pages which is
women in Iran who post pictures of
themselves without their head scarves
which violates law and there's this
great picture of a grandmother a mother
and her daughter and the grandmother
saying I wanted my granddaughter to feel
the wind on her hair and her hair before
her hair turns gray that is their voice
Facebook is also about the women who
proudly wear scarves because that's
their belief and they post pictures of
themselves in that that's giving
individuals voice when you think about
the history of being able to communicate
before Facebook before social media you
had to be you or me or be able to get on
local TV to have a voice be able to get
an article written the paper and not
everyone can do that
but now anyone anywhere in the world can
share what they really feel and what
they
really think and I think that gets power
to people and that is so important with
Lenin it's really the same thing it's
about giving women voice and giving
women the ability to believe they can
the world's too often tells women what
they can't do or what they shouldn't do
and we can change that ask the audience
one more question and then only men
please raise your hand if anyone's ever
said should you be working David Dreier
should you be working men anyone women
raise your hand if anyone's ever said to
you should you be working seventy
percent of mothers in the United States
work because they need to telling women
they can't work and be mothers is absurd
and insulting and goes against the
economic reality most women face and so
we can give people voice we can tell
them they can and help them come
together to fulfill their ambitions it's
a nice note and now we're going to turn
it over to our audience so your the
roles I please would wait for the mic
I'll call on you the mic will come to
you please stand up and say who you are
and what your affiliation is and if you
have a protest statement just make it a
new question let's say whose first
question here let's see right here and
race it off and Mike's coming to you
Andre I'm surprised you know my name is
andrei sitov I'm a Russian reporter here
in DC with us now I know what my friends
at the Treasury aspire for now that I
see you you have used a company the
Facebook has huge following all over the
world including including Russia but my
question is about journalism a theatre
it has been touched upon a little bit
you G find the Facebook as a technical
company not a news company but you are
also a purveyor of
news huge amounts of information right
to people all over the world how do you
see the synergies between your type of
business and the regular news business
what what can the two do to each other
for each other help each other and the
since I am from Russia
obviously I have a question when will we
have NFP office so the answer to that
Facebook office in Russia is I don't
know we we tend to follow our users and
follow the advertising opportunities and
opening up offices the answer on the
journalism question is obviously the
media industry is in flux and it's going
through a change in business model that
accompanies technological change and how
news is distributed what we do best for
news companies right now is get
distribution and give voice so reporters
post publications post their very
important partners to us because we are
able to get more people to read their
articles and get more people to share I
think the other thing we do and we
hopefully do well is give people a way
to interact directly with their readers
so some of the best journalists out
there will post and say hey I'm about to
interview this person what should I ask
that builds their audience and in turn
their organization builds monetization
for them as well well we want to make
sure that people who provide the content
have a good experience that when they
share they get what they want which is
people to read their articles and an
ability to monetize we're gonna go back
here and then we're going to come up to
earning Choksi thanks Thank You author
good afternoon Sheryl huge huge huge fan
I've been tweeting both of you like
crazy Facebook by the way I'm a member
of a Leadership Network I'm a small
business owner and thank you sure offer
empowering me to create a woman
empowerment network that I did here in
DC yes my question and especially in a
political environment I want to talk
about bullying and words on Facebook we
all see it in our personal feeds we all
see it on news articles and that is does
Facebook feel that it has to do
something around bullying we all see it
the posts can put an article up and then
all of a sudden people are yelling and
screaming at each other in the comment
section what is Facebook doing to
address bullying and what are you doing
to help us as users to improve our
dialog with each other it's a great
question and we feel very strongly that
there is no place for hate and no place
for bullying on Facebook we have strict
policies against bullying we rely on
users to report probably the most
important thing we've done and it goes
to exactly how you asked your question
is we've helped people have better
communication with each other so if you
put up a picture and of a friend or you
put up a post and your friend doesn't
like it we've enabled social reporting
tools where I can report to you please
take that down we've learned over time
that if we help you make it emotional
language please please take that down
we'll get some people to respond please
take that down it hurts my feelings
please take that down it really bothers
me that's up and you are actually quite
likely to respond and it turns out the
ability to communicate builds empathy
with each other and most of what people
minds not all but most can actually be
solved person to person on Facebook
because people are willing to be kind to
each other sometimes it can't be and
when that bullying is reported we work
we work very hard to take it down and
we've worked with schools and parents
and local organizations all over the
world thanks for that I mean right up
here arming Choksey you talked about
content policy that you have regarding
terrorism but we hear a lot of stories
about the internet being used by the
ISIS and others to radicalize homegrown
terrorists is it his Facebook at all
involved in this in any way shape or
form do you stop it or is it all taking
part in the dump the deep and dark web
so there's just no place for terrorism
on Facebook we take it incredibly
seriously there's no place for violence
we take things down as soon as we find
them we're also pretty happy that people
will often say Facebook is not the place
of choice for terrorists because we have
real name identity and that actually
goes to part of the answer on bullying
as well people are less likely to do
these things when they
have real identity because their name
and face is associated with it you can
see this in the media and comments if
you look at some media websites where
people are posting anonymously you'll
see one form of comment then some of
these sites will enable Facebook posting
where your real name and photo is
attached to what you say and I'm not
gonna pretend the comments are perfect
but there are a lot nicer and so real
identity I think is one very strong way
we protect against this do you think
that in just in the general world I mean
one of the biggest problems that we have
there's a very interesting art let me
preface this there's a very interesting
article that I saw last year that showed
that that anonymous commentary on the
internet after news stories is actually
a leading indicator of psychosis
sociopathy and so basically what this
says is if you you know those who are
worried about dating somebody who's
controlling in our system you should
just casually ask on the first date do
you ever you know write anonymously your
comments on the news article you know
and then it's like red lights going out
this the whole idea but but just in
general is it your view that that
anonymity is is an enemy of an open
society where people treat each other
well do you think we should be working
against anonymity I mean there are
services where people want to be
anonymous and services where people want
to have authentic identity it is my view
that authentic identity is a good
enabler of good behavior for sure
authentic identity helps the most
important thing that goes right on
Facebook is authentic identity because
when you're posting you're Arthur Brooks
and it says who you are and I know who
you are and I can respond it's also the
case that a lot of what has to happen
not all but does happen person to person
so to the great woman back there who
started the Women's Network on Facebook
you know a lot of what happens is people
come together to support each other when
it can or even when they post something
they don't like they come together to
fix it oh all right who's next let's go
over here in the corner she was at our
meeting last much
hey I'm Mary Catherine ham how you doing
yeah one of the things I like about Lena
and the conversation around it is that
it does focus on it's not just a policy
prescription it focuses on how we help
each other as a group how women can get
together these sort of outside of
government structures that that we can
do a lot with as a conservative I love
those things
I read your mother's day post with
interests as a woman who did also become
a single mom suddenly and I found there
were some policy prescriptions than that
here's no question I'm just pushing back
a little bit do you think that when we
talk about single moms because we
sometimes lean on the policy
prescriptions we miss opportunities to
create those outside government
structures that Lena and has been
interested in doing yeah
leaning is focused on outside government
structures we are very nonpartisan there
and have circles all over the world of
of all types and the circles are focused
on individual action so we have a free
curriculum up there we have videos and
other educational guides and every
single one is very practical so if you
watch the video there's always something
you can do and you can do that day so
for example you know women don't get
paid as much as men women don't get paid
as much as men anywhere in the world you
know the first time to practice having
the conversation where you ask for more
money is not with your boss do that with
your friends figure out how to negotiate
and practice it in circles and we see
and we see that changing and we see that
that working and so we're very focused
on individual action and part of
individual action for people at certain
times and for me for single mothers is
advocating for policy but that can only
ever be part I think there are very good
examples out there of why policy can't
be all of the answer and one example I
look to is you look at Norway Norway has
had strong quotas for women in
government and women on boards and
they've had quotas over a decade at 40%
and that's worked to get women in
government at 40% and and into boards
yeah I mean II what companies in Norway
are run by women three point four
percent and so people have differing
views on policy and policy can be very
pardon but policy will never be
sufficient because this is the culture
this is about whether or not we want and
encourage female leadership and we're
gonna have to change that person by
person working together hmm
cultural change beats policy change
interesting very good right back here hi
my name is Aileen Chen I'm an intern
with AEI Asia studies team first of all
thank you so much for being here it's a
great honor my question is about
Facebook's policy with China could you
update us a little bit about what
Facebook is currently doing with China
and if the Chinese market will ever be
opened thank you so it's a timely
question I was just in China last week I
serve on the Disney board and we opened
Disney and Shanghai and it was really
exciting right now we are not available
or service is not available within the
Chinese market we do however have a
growing business in China which is that
we're working with Chinese companies to
help them sell their products overseas
so Chinese companies are using us to
reach external markets and so we're
encouraged by that and we've always said
we would like to connect the world and
we would one day like to have a business
in China as well we've just about run
out of time I'm gonna have time for just
one more question and so we're just
gonna bail the hand and I'm gonna
actually have to do it I'm gonna take it
from a woman and go right back behind
you Stephanie right here in the in the
blue with the blacks with the black
jacket hi I'm a web developer at AEI my
name is Neha Coyle being a woman in
technology being a woman of minority how
can I give back to the community I've
had a lot of opportunities being I grew
up in India and I came to he came to us
first for being a proud in an American
what can I do to give back to the
community having all these opportunities
well I wouldn't underestimate the
example you set by staying in technology
we need more women who are technical we
need more women in the field and by
staying in you show other women you can
stay in you can also mentor other women
sponsor other women help women start
circles and build technology people use
to express themselves so I think there's
a lot you can do the world is also in it
too maybe a great note to end on the
world is also increasingly a little
and so increasingly what you do today
what you build what you say can
reverberate not just in this room but
around the world and so I look forward
to the impact you're gonna have on women
in tech on tech and for Indians all over
and by the way your work at AEI is
helping the world that's right she's
giving back right now and every day I
want to thank all of you for joining us
and invite all of you to join me in
thanking Sheryl Sandberg
[Applause]
[Music]